Trascrizione: Chiara Rossini
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Allora, buonasera a tutti.
Dalla realtà artificiale di Federico
vi riporto sulla realtà
quotidiana, invece,
di quello che succede tutti i giorni
guardando la televisione,
aprendo i giornali, su Internet.
Siamo ovviamente invasi, tutti i giorni,
da tantissime notizie.
Io nella mia professione,
mi sono quasi esclusivamente
occupata di cronaca,
sia da inviato prima,
che da vice caporedattore adesso.
Ma capire quanto l'intuizione conti
nel nostro lavoro,
nella professione del giornalista,
vale ovviamente in tutti i campi:
dall'informazione politica,
economica, sociale e culturale.
Io ovviamente vi parlo di quella che è
la mia esperienza personale.
Lo dicevo prima: il giornalismo
si basa sui fatti.
[Il che] significa, da una parte,
raccontare la realtà,
i fatti che succedono,
che abbiano lì davanti a noi,
e poi cercare di capire
le cause di quella realtà;
dall'altra significa andare a scoprire
anche le realtà più nascoste.
E lì c'è il giornalismo d'inchiesta,
andare a scavare, andare ad approfondire.
Tutto questo succede
in tutte le redazioni:
nella carta stampata, per la radio,
per la televisione, per internet:
per tutti i mezzi d'informazione.
È un lavoro dunque
molto concreto, che si basa sui fatti;
dove però l'intuizione è molto importante.
Vi farò alcuni esempi:
in alcuni casi il fatto è eclatante,
cioé la notizia è lì, davanti a noi,
impossibile da non vedere
e quindi, teoricamente,
molto più facile da raccontare.
Un esempio su tutti, lo avrete presente,
lo ricorderete: la Costa Concordia.
Il naufragio della Costa Concordia
davanti all'Isola del Giglio.
La nave appena naufragata
era lì, davanti a tutti:
quindi, come dire, un fatto semplice,
da un primo punto di vista, da raccontare.
Io quel giorno ero responsabile
della redazione cronaca,
la mattina subito dopo il naufragio.
E vi racconto appunto
come ci si comporta in questi casi.
La prima cosa da fare, ovviamente,
davanti a un fatto così importante,
è fare subito partire gli inviati,
cioè i colleghi che vanno sul posto,
che ci raccontano che cosa sta succedendo,
quello che vedono,
che raccolgano le testimonianze
delle persone, dei sopravvissuti.
Ma dopo aver fatto queste prime cose -
che di solito, appunto, sono le cose
che si fanno nella prima emergenza,
che cosa - qui scatta la domanda -
che cosa possiamo fare in più
per riuscire a trovare qualcosa
che vada al di là del semplice racconto
di quel che è successo?
Ecco, qui entra in gioco l'intuizione:
cioè cosa posso raccontare di più
per fare capire maggiormente
quello che sta succedendo?
Per esempio, poche ore dopo
il naufragio della Concordia
quasi tutti avevano già a disposizione,
ovviamente, le immagini della nave:
ve la ricordate, no?
Posata su un fianco
davanti all'Isola del Giglio.
I primi racconti dei sopravvissuti,
cioè di tutti i passeggeri che, ormai,
erano stati tratti in salvo
e portati a terra.
Un primo bilancio
delle vittime e dei dispersi,
che poi ovviamente,
nel corso dei giorni, è aumentato.
A questo punto, ecco,
dopo qualche ora dal naufragio,
voi avete queste cose.
Che cosa vi manca?
Vi faccio una domanda:
avete le immagini della nave,
avete il racconto dei primi sopravvissuti,
avete un primo bilancio
delle persone che mancano all'appello,
quindi delle vittime e dei dispersi.
Che cosa vi manca?
Di che cosa sentite di aver bisogno?
- (Pubblico) Le cause.
- CR: Poi?
E quello ovviamente, cercare le cause, no?
Ci vorrà tempo per capirlo.
- (Pubblico): (Indistinguibile)
- CR: Ovviamente, cos'altro?
- CR: Vi manca un altro elemento.
Le testimonianze ce le hai,
cioè i sopravvissuti sono arrivati a terra
e ti hanno raccontato
cos'è successo quella notte.
[Mentre mi chiedevo]:
"Cosa ci manca in quel momento?"
a me è venuto in mente questo:
mi mancano le immagini da dentro la nave,
le immagini che mi raccontino
quei momenti in cui sono -
ci sono stati gli avvisi a bordo,
non si capiva che cosa stesse succedendo,
le persone che salivano
sulle scialuppe di salvataggio,
quella è stata l'intuizione.
A quel punto, con una collega, ho detto:
dobbiamo cercare qualcuno
dei sopravvissuti
che ovviamente abbia girato qualcosa
visto che adesso, con i telefonini,
giriamo immagini in qualsiasi situazione.
Quindi è stato un lavoro non facile
perché all'inizio sembra scontato, no?
Nei giorni successivi, ve lo ricorderete,
siamo stati invasi da immagini
riprese a bordo della nave.
Ma nelle prime ore
è stato molto difficile:
ci siamo riusciti,
e la sera stessa
del primo giorno del naufragio
siamo riusciti a mandare in onda
questi primi frammenti,
con le voci drammatiche di qui momenti,
le possiamo vedere.
- (Passeggeri): Siamo tutti
col salvagente -
Sì sì, a destra. L'allarme della nave.
- (Dialetto): Uhhh. . tutta da 'na parte.
- (Intervistatore): Come 'na frenata?
E poi boom, e n'artra così proprio -
scivolavano i tavoli, i bicchieri,
i camerieri, porelli, tutti pieni de tera,
e poi la luce spenta, te po' immagina'.
(voci non distinguibili)
"Ripeto recarsi alle mappe svelto
ai punti di riunione al ponte quattro
e seguire le istruzioni
del nostro personale, mantenendo la calma"
"Ma quelli della nave che vi dicevano?"
"No, niente! Non s'è visto nessuno:
per il comandante tutto andava bene,
ed è pure registrato perché ho detto:
Qui ci dicono che tutto
va bene, registriamo"
(Voci indistinguibili)
"Ma no' hai sentito che botto?"
"Ma è piegata! È piegata, vero?"
"Dopo non hanno potuto
togliere le scialuppe
perché ormai tra 'n po'
saremo dentro l'acqua,
Allora ci hanno mandato da un'altra parte
e hanno detto "Andate dall'altra parte"
Non sai se devi andare a destra,
se devi andare a sinistra:
alla fine siamo andati lì
e ci hanno fatto scendere,
E poi, se ci avessero mai preso
saremmo pentiti pure d'andarci
perché stava a ricadere tutto
Intervistatrice: - e lasciamo stare.
Passeggera: "da morire!"
"Ave Maria piena di grazia,
il Signore è con te.
Tu sei benedetta e benedetto
è il frutto del seno tuo Gesù.
Santa Maria madre di Dio,
prega per noi peccatori,
adesso e nell'ora
della nostra morte, amen.
Ave Maria, piena di grazia..."
(Passeggera) -Credo si siano salvati
e io gli ho detto:
"Forse era meglio che rimanevamo lì"
Perché si stava girando pure la scialuppa,
noi non sappiamo nuotare,
la paura era tripla,
però che fai?
Se è il tuo momento,
che venga a prenderti.
(voci indistinguibili)
Da duri che eravamo, ho detto:
"Guarda che bello quello!
Guarda che bello!"
Ho fatto: "Me sembra di stare nel Titanic.
È inaffondabile" ho detto io.
"Eh, questa però
deve essere inaffondabile"
Dopo due ore e mezza,
era affondata pure lei.
Racconto un po' così, no?
La signora cerca di sdrammatizzare
quello che è successo,
è stata appunto la signora
con la sua testimonianza,
con la sua macchina fotografica,
che ha girato questo video.
Quindi, ecco:
quello della Concordia è un esempio
di come sia importante
avere un'intuizione, un'idea
un momento prima degli altri.
Poi sono arrivati tutti gli altri,
sono arrivati tutti gli altri video.
Ci sono altri casi
in cui entra in gioco l'intuizione.
Intuizione è anche capire
da poche righe, da una piccola notizia,
da un piccolo trafiletto
su un giornale locale
che quel tema diventerà importante,
che si guadagnerà
la prima pagina dei giornali.
Vi faccio un altro esempio:
vi ricorderete quest'estate,
questo è un caso molto recente,
il caso scoppiato sulla processione
di Oppido Mamertina, in Calabria,
quando la statua fu fatta fermare
davanti alla casa di un boss
in segno di omaggio, al boss del paese.
Ecco, all'inizio questa notizia
è uscita come un piccolo trafiletto
su un giornale locale.
Poi qualche giorno dopo, addirittura,
quindi non il giorno stesso,
un giornale nazionale
lo ha pubblicato sul suo sito online;
la mattina era molto basso, quindi insomma
non tra le notizie più importanti
poi nel corso della giornata
questa notizia "è salita",
come diciamo noi in gergo:
è diventata una notizia nazionale
ed è scoppiata, poi,
tutta la polemica che vi ricorderete.
Un altro caso importante,
un caso di cronaca degli ultimi anni:
tutti ricorderete la vicenda
della morte di Stefano Cucchi,
proprio martedì scorso è iniziato
il processo d'appello qui a Roma.
Ecco: la morte improvvisa di Stefano,
con gli evidenti segni
di percosse sul corpo
fu segnalata alla nostra redazione
proprio il giorno stesso della sua morte
da un avvocato
che si era occupato
di un altro caso importante:
quello di Federico Aldrovandi,
il ragazzo morto a Ferrara.
Ecco, il capo redattore -
che in quel momento, appunto,
stava lavorando -
ha avuto l'intuizione
dell'importanza di quella segnalazione,
notizia di cui nessuno,
ovviamente, parlava
perché non era uscita
su nessuna agenzia di stampa,
da nessuna parte -
ha assegnato il caso ad un collega
che ha contattato la sorella
di Stefano, Ilaria Cucchi,
e abbiamo così raccolto,
proprio il giorno dopo
la morte di Stefano,
il 23 ottobre del 2009,
la denuncia della sorella.
Vediamo quest'altro video:
Ilaria Cucchi: Mio fratello
era un ragazzo di 31 anni
che la notte tra giovedì e venerdì
della settimana scorsa
è stato arrestato in una zona di Roma
per detenzione di sostanze stupefacenti,
e l'epilogo è stato
che ieri abbiamo avuto
la notizia del suo decesso
presso l'ospedale Pertini di Roma,
reparto carcerario.
(Intervistatore) Cioè, lui era in carcere
quando è morto, praticamente?
IC: Sì.
- Lei ha visto il suo corpo?
IC: Io l'ho visto qui all'obitorio,
sì, dietro un vetro.
- E cosa ha visto?
IC: Una scena indescrivibile:
il viso completamente pieno
di segni, di lividi,
aveva un'occhio fuori dalle orbite,
aveva la mascella visibilmente rotta;
e non ho visto il corpo,
perché il corpo era coperto dal lenzuolo.
- Quindi lei sospetta fortemente
che suo fratello
sia stato picchiato in carcere?
- IC: Da solo non se
l'è fatte, quelle cose.
- Quindi quando suo fratello
è stato arrestato stava bene,
i suoi genitori l'hanno visto?
IC: Assolutamente sì.
- Voi siete andati a trovarlo in ospedale?
IC: Siamo andati
a trovarlo in ospedale
ma ovviamente nessuno ha saputo,
o voluto, dire nulla.
Non ci davano alcun tipo di notizia.
La scusa era che era un carcere
e non si poteva assolutamente
dare nessuna notizia.
Io vorrei giustizia, vorrei chiarezza
perché da solo mio fratello
quelle cose non se l'è fatte.
Qualcuno ha sbagliato,
qualcuno deve pagare, assolutamente.
E dopo quest'intervista, ovviamente,
il caso è diventato un caso nazionale,
e appunto, come ho detto,
il processo è ancora in corso.
Abbiamo visto solo alcuni esempi
di come una notizia
possa nascere da un'intuizione;
questo succede,
dovrebbe succedere almeno,
tutti i giorni, in ogni redazione;
a volte può bastare
anche un frammento di una notizia,
di un'informazione ricevuta,
a volte, anche involontariamente;
e da cui partire;
a quel punto l'intuizione, poi,
ci porta ad approfondire,
a quel giornalismo d'inchiesta
di cui parlavo, di cui parlavo all'inizio.
Andare a scavare,
trovare le informazioni nascoste
e poi arrivare anche, in alcuni casi,
a degli scoop come li chiamiamo noi,
quando si riesce a trovare
la notizia veramente importante.
Secondo alcuni esperti
di media internazionali,
l'intuizione sarà uno degli aspetti
sempre più importanti
nel giornalismo del futuro,
ormai dominato dalle nuove tecnologie
e quindi dalla velocità
con cui arrivano le notizie,
praticamente in tempo reale.
Ecco, ma come può nascere un'intuizione
nel nostro campo,
nella nostra professione?
Oggi li abbiamo visti
in tanti altri campi.
Ovviamente serve esperienza,
serve un'adeguata formazione,
serve leggere tantissimo:
non solo i titoli dei giornali online,
serve leggere il vecchio giornale
cartaceo, di carta,
che ormai nessuno quasi compra più,
perché nei piccoli trafiletti,
nelle piccole notizie,
si può nascondere quella che domani
sarà la notizia del giorno;
ma soprattutto, io questo
lo ripeto sempre ai colleghi,
ma soprattutto ai più giovani,
che cominciano adesso
a fare questo lavoro,
serve la curiosità,
questa è la cosa
alla base del nostro lavoro.
La curiosità di cercare di capire,
di chiedere, di cercare di andare oltre.
Oggi vi racconto solo brevemente
quest'ultimo, la cosa
che m'è capitata oggi a pranzo.
Eravamo seduti con un'altra collega,
e avevamo di fronte due ragazzi.
Parlando,
una ragazza ci ha detto
di essere una neolaureata
in un corso di laurea
che io non conoscevo:
"Scienze per le tecnologie
per la conservazione dei beni culturali"
una cosa che quasi nessuno
conosce in Italia.
Sta lavorando ad un progetto
interessantissimo
su un laser che serve,
applicato a tutte le opere d'arte,
per cercare appunto
di prevenirne l'invecchiamento,
per dare lo stato dei colori.
Insomma, un meccanismo molto complesso:
che però viene usato pochissimo,
è quasi sconosciuto in Italia.
"Questo laser sta per essere smontato",
mi diceva la ragazza,
"perché non ci sono i fondi".
E questo, mi si è accesa
la famosa lampadina
e io ho detto: "Beh dobbiamo parlarne:
dammi il numero di telefono
perché adesso il TG3
se ne vorrà occupare".
Parlando, da piccole conversazioni,
possono nascere poi delle notizie.
Speriamo insomma che anche questa
possa essere una notizia
da far conoscere fuori.
Quindi, vi dicevo, la curiosità.
È già stata citata precedentemente
la scena de 'L'attimo fuggente'
con il professore che invita gli studenti
a salire sui banchi
per vedere la realtà
da un altro punto di vista.
Questo serve, per far
nascere un'intuizione.
Vorrei chiudere con una citazione
di Marcel Proust, che diceva:
"La vera scoperta non consiste
nel trovare nuovi territori,
ma nel vederli con nuovi occhi."
È da lì, che scatta l'intuizione.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)